welcome back to omix logic data science
let us now review some of the omics data
types used in biomedical research a lot
of the data we will talk about in this
session is unstructured and therefore it
has to be processed before it is made
useful for analysis or machine learning
some of the data types used in
biomedical research you might be well
familiar with types of patients disease
stages or drug response but others you
might be learning some new things for
the first time such as genomics or
metagenomics
collectively these data types are known
as omics data each type can be generated
using a similar technique but there will
be many differences in how we can
prepare each one of these data types and
structure structured for analysis
let's start from the beginning what is
data science data science relies on
information technologies and analytical
methods to extract meaning from data in
the case of biological data that can
include basic research biotechnology
biomedicine genomics agriculture and
many other domains in this video we will
start reviewing some of these basic
properties of biological data as the
data itself is changing and what do
these changes mean for the analytical
techniques and the skills one needs to
have to deal with such data effectively
data science involves developing methods
of recording storing and analyzing data
to effectively extract useful
information practical information
actionable information the goal of data
science is to gain insights and
knowledge from any type of data both
structured and unstructured
but the majority of data is unstructured
and therefore
it has to be processed before we can
analyze it to make it useful so what is
structured and unstructured data
unstructured data can include images
emails reviews
maybe sounds or speech the way it
naturally comes out
to structure it first many times we try
to force structure for example we can
provide categories that we know are
useful
maybe these are folders that you can
organize your data in hashtags like we
see on twitter but structured data
ideally is something that is easy to
analyze and most analysis methods work
on numeric data
so to illustrate the concept of
unstructured data let us try to conduct
a survey if i ask you what is your
educational background you might respond
in many different ways for example i'm
studying biochemistry i have a degree in
computer science i have a bachelor's in
biotechnology or i'm a graduate student
so instead we tend to structure surveys
replacing the actual information that
somebody would share with a code for a
category that we know how to analyze as
a result you can see bachelor's degree
master's degree phd or faculty now if i
ask the question in such a way a lot of
the depth of the information that you
might be willing to share is now missing
so as a result of us trying to scale up
this process and simplify the collection
of data to analysis of data for
actionable insights we are depending on
efficient ways to process data so for
example when we are collecting this data
and it looks like this we might have to
perform a number of processing steps to
actually turn data into something that
we can
analyze and even visualize so that many
people can look at it and intuitively
understand
the same would be true for any kind of
data but especially big data big data
has certain characteristics that we have
to keep in mind velocity variability and
volume
to make sense of such data we need to
process it and prepared for analysis
linking elements reducing noise and
making sure that we have the right kind
of information
that could be analyzed
in the case of biomedicine big data is
generated across research clinical
practice and biotechnology industry
in research there is a growing trend for
automating high throughput data
collections such as omics in the
clinical domain this includes genotyping
imaging patient records and insurance
data and in biotechnology advances in
high throughput drug screening
real world patient response monitoring
and mathematical models of
epidemiological or individual patient
patterns are all resulting in growing
data needs
and technical challenges
as a result of being able to deal with
these challenges
and learn how to process data
researchers clinicians and industry are
making novel discoveries that include
new treatments diagnostic assays and
design strategies for experimentation
to take a look at what kind of data is
out there we can just simply look at
some of these publicly available data
repositories one of them is called the
national center for biotechnology
information or ncbi which has a
collection of peer-reviewed articles
biological data sets organized into bio
projects that cover a variety of topics
observing these repositories we can find
that the number of data sets in them is
growing exponentially but also
variability of data types continues to
expand due to new technologies that are
emerging and are being adopted by a
growing number of labs and researchers
so as a result each data set has to be
approached with a series of steps that
include processing
exploratory analysis and model selection
for inference due to the volume
variability and velocity of data many of
these steps have to be automated that
introduces a component of
algorithm-based analysis which is
essentially a big part of machine
learning
now let's take a moment to review
several different types of omics data
and think about what are the steps that
are needed to structure this data for
analysis and how can this analysis
reveal important information that is
actionable
omix data can include phenomics genomics
epigenomics and metagenomics omix
technologies like next generation
sequencing can be used to explore the
roles relationships and actions of the
various types of molecules that make up
the cells of an organism
many types of omnics data can be
generated with the same technique and
the data can show specific information
about invariants patterns of gene
expression or maybe microbes that are
present in a sample
to structure our mixed data we need to
take raw sequencing which are strings of
letters
t c g and a and generate a data set or a
matrix of continuous and categorical
data that then can be analyzed to do
that we organize processing steps in
sequences that we will refer to as
pipelines because one process takes the
output of the previous step and prepares
it for the next step and so it's like
water flowing in a pipe pipelines are
specific to each type of omics data with
specific inputs and outputs
for example genomic data with shotgun
sequencing genomic data generates short
reads of
sequences t c g and a sequences from
randomly selected fragments of dna these
fragments
have to be aligned to the reference
genome once aligned one short read can
be analyzed for matches and non-matches
to the reference sequence in oncology
the non-matches are analyzed for their
mutational status
in many cases somatic mutations are
called to understand how they might
affect important genes involved in tumor
growth and disease progression
to analyze such data we can prepare a
table of somatic scores for each genome
position where we have a dna position
and a somatic score that reveals the
important positions to pay attention to
as a result we can compile a smaller
file
of just variance or vcf variant call
file such a file can be visualized by
annotating the positions that we
identified as important with positions
of genes
and mutations that have been stored in a
database so for example here you can see
a comparison of mutations in an
important gene called p53 according to
different types of tumors grades of
tumors as well as risk factors
to achieve such results we have to take
raw data or fast q files with short
reads run a pipeline for variant calling
and get an output of tables or vcf files
the pipeline might include several
pre-processing mapping and somatic
variant calling steps to ultimately
produce the table that we can then
analyze for statistical significance of
found variance
to learn more about such analysis of
genomic data you can review additional
detailed tutorials included in the
genomics course where you will see the
basic concepts and principles of
genomics
explore genomic data analysis
processing
single nucleotide variation as well as
all the way to variant detection and
interpretation
another example is transcriptomic data
such data represents mrna expression
which is a good way to analyze what
processes are going on inside the cell
by observing active transcription of
protein coding genes
dna is transcribed to rna and rna is
translated into protein which defines
the phenotype of a cell
but protein coding genes in genomic dna
contain large stretches of non-coding
sequences called introns that are
spliced out of the rna transcript by an
enzymatic complex called the spliceosome
before it is passed to the ribosome 4
translation
the parts of the gene that remain in the
mature processed mrna transcript are
called exons these are the parts that
encode the amino acid sequences used for
protein translation by the ribosome a
typical analysis pipeline for rna-seq
data allows us to map reads to the
reference genome to understand how genes
are expressed and what variation in
alternative splicing leads to
transcripts that ultimately define the
phenotype this pipeline can include
pre-processing mapping quantification
and differential gene expression steps
as a result you might obtain a table of
continuous numeric data annotated by
gene id and organized consistently
across samples in a given experiment
with a level of expression in each cell
the full process of rna-seq data
analysis can be separated into several
analysis steps for processing
exploratory analysis hypothesis testing
and interpretation
to learn much more about transcriptomic
data analysis and each one of the steps
like pre-processing mapping
quantification and differential analysis
you can take the transcriptomics course
that we have on the portal
there you will also learn about specific
challenges for rnac data analysis in
small sample data sets and large-scale
studies where machine learning is used
for data mining visualization and
classification of patients
another type of data that we will review
in this course come from the same
sequencing technique but provides us
with a completely different view of a
biological sample
in this case we're talking about
metagenomics where we are looking at a
sample that contains millions of
microorganisms represented by genomes
that are very different from each other
to structure this data and organize
genomic information into categories we
can take a functionally related gene
that is common to all of the organisms
that we're looking for for example they
have a shared function like the ribosome
which can be compared to a database of
known sequences that has already been
annotated now we need to denoise the
sequence data and then map those
sequences of found specific genes the
16s ribosomal rna genes to a database to
classify found sequences into closely
related taxonomic groups
this is commonly referred to as 16s
ribosomal rna amplicon data analysis
that can be done on the tbi info
platform using the data 2 pipeline
as a result you will obtain a proportion
of taxonomic groups across samples with
analysis of sample diversity or
proportionate abundance of specific
microorganisms that might be linked to
phenotypic variation
the basic type of structure data in this
case is also called a table of otus or
operational taxonomic units across
samples with proportionate abundance in
each cell
in addition each otu can be linked to
taxonomic groups by kingdom phylum class
order family genus or species
to learn more about such analysis and
see several use cases of microbial
sequencing in clinical or environmental
projects you can take the metagenomics
course that we have on the portal